Republican Senator
Tommy Tuberville
is doubling down over his comments
over white nationalism
that he shared last night
with our Kaitlan Collins.
Real kept repeating
that it's just an opinion
that white nationalist are indeed racist,
although the definition says so.
CNN's Lauren Fox is on Capitol Hill
with the very latest.
Lauren, what are you hearing now
Yeah,
I mean, Tuberville
just continues
doubling down on his comments.
Originally, he made these comments
weeks ago basically arguing
that white nationalists
weren't necessarily racist.
And he was pressed
repeatedly by our Kaitlan
Collins yesterday
and then pressed
repeatedly by reporters again today.
Here's what he said.
Explain why you continue to insist
that white nationalists are American.
Listen, I'm totally against racism.
If the Democrats want to say
that white nationalists are racist,
I'm totally against that, too.
But that's not a Democratic definition.
The definition of a white nationalist
definition, by definition, it is racism.
Bad and the definition. The definition.
The definition is that the belief
that the right race is superior to
racism is totally out of the question.
So do you believe that
white nationalists are racist? Yes.
If that's what racism is. Yes.
Thank you. But
And he just
continues to
double down in the fallout
on Capitol Hill from Republicans
is now that many Republicans
are being asked by reporters
or white nationalists racist.
And I talked to several Republicans,
including Rick Scott of Florida,
who said absolutely,
that is the definition
of a white nationalist that they believe
that the white race
is superior to other races.
You also heard from John Thune,
who I spoke to just moments ago.
He is the Republican whip
and he was pressed by reporters
whether or not
he was going to talk directly
to Thomasville about his comments.
He said he had no idea
what Tuberville
was actually trying to say.
He said, just to be clear, though,
there is no room for white nationalists
in the Republican Party.
I pressed him
on whether or not
there was room
for white nationalists in the military.
He said, no,
not there
either, making it clear
that he wants to put this to bed.
He does not want this to become a broader
question of whether or not Republicans
are sticking with white nationalists.
Sarah.
Yeah, hard to put it to bed
when you keep getting those same answers
from Tuberville.
Thank you so much, Lauren
Fox, for that update. Appreciate it.
It's obviously not an opinion.
It is a fact that white nationalism,
white nationalists are racist.
Why do you think it is so hard
for Senator Tuberville
to be clear about that?
So it's interesting.
Good to see you.
But, you know, here's what's happening.
So
if you listen to the full interview
for somebody that claims
to be very clear spoken,
and I'm just going to tell you
how I feel,
he is
twisting his words
around to please everybody.
So he's trying to pretend like,
well, white nationalists are Americans
if they're racist, I'm against racism.
But, you know,
it's only your opinion
that white nationalism is racism.
So that way
he's trying to create a situation
where everybody can hear
what they want to hear,
because honestly, there is a constituency
of white nationalists
that you don't want to tick off, evident
in some of the Republican primaries
because they're loud on the Internet
or they have the ear of,
you know, certain people.
And so I think he is trying
to twist his words
and he does not want to.
It's a lot of what you saw,
frankly, with Donald Trump
where he didn't want to alienate
the proud boys and stuff like that.
So it's a really,
really concerning thing.
Let's be very clear.
White nationalism is not just racism.
It's deep racism.
And it has no place, in my opinion,
in any political party.
And it certainly has no place
in the United States military.
Historically, the GOP likes to
embrace that. It is pro-military.
And the Pentagon itself has said
yes, there is a problem
with white nationalism.
There is a problem with extremism
in its ranks.
What does it do to the Republican Party's
historic support of the military
for it
to be home to a senator
who is saying something like this
by the way?
I want to be clear. It's true.
There is extremism in the military.
Now, I'm not.
Not necessarily at a greater rate
than all of the country,
but I've seen people like
I've seen
people tell me, I've had people tell me
QAnon theories
that are wearing the uniform
of the United States military.
And so, yes, we have to weed that out.
Just like when I joined the military,
I had to say
I am not a member of the Communist Party
or any party
or any group
that seeks to overturn
the United States government.
And so what it does
for the historical Republican support,
they can pretend like continue to pretend
like they are the pro-military party
as they oppose U.S.
support to Afghan or to Ukraine,
which actually
is preventing
the United States military
from having to get involved
directly against Russia,
you know,
as they
hold up nominations
because of the difference
on abortion opinion
and have these members of the military
that are relying on their promotions
for better pay, for better leadership,
the military that needs them
to fill these positions,
holding them up for politics. So, look,
there's plenty of
criticism that can go around
in terms of politicizing the military.
In this case,
it is the Republicans
or more specifically Tommy Tuberville
that's doing exactly that.
So he all of this is spawning,
sort of spinning off of the fact
that he is unilaterally holding up
these military nominations
right over the Pentagon's abortion
leave policy.
How problematic is it?
And we're seeing this really affect,
right, the nomination
for the chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff?
How problematic is it for Republicans
that this GOP senator
who cannot condemn white nationalism
as racist is holding up the nomination
of an African-American general
to be chairman of the Joint Chiefs
Well, I think it's quite problematic.
Now, I've kind of come to believe
that when it comes to base politics,
there's really nothing somebody can do
that's going to change the support
among the base unfortunately.
But you can chip away at it.
And people, I think
especially Alabama,
has got a pretty significant
military presence.
There's going to be a lot of people
that are actually personally
affected by this.
Look,
I don't even think anybody
like Rand Paul,
who is very anti-military,
quite honestly, has taken it
this far before.
And so this is damaging
to the Republican brand.
It's damaging to Tommy Tuberville.
So I guess he can win over some of the
he's probably
already won
over the anti-abortion folks,
but maybe he can win them
over even harder.
But even the Republicans in
the Senate are saying this is insane.
This is insane.
I mean, we can't talk about competition
with China
and blame
President Biden
for some lack of competition with China
and then hold up the nominations
of the military
that is actively every day preparing for
hopefully not actually
engaging in competition
or conflict with China.
That's the only way to prevent it.
And Tommy
Tuberville is doing great damage to that.
Yeah.
And those are
some of the actual nominations
that we're talking about, right,
when it comes to the Navy
and the fleets
that are dealing with the China threat.
Former Congressman Adam Kinzinger,
thank you so much for your time.
We appreciate it.